ces montagnes sont situés au milieu du
plus grand désert de la terre le sahara
il traverse toute la largeur de
l'afrique en s'étendant sur une
superficie de plus de 7 millions et demi
de kilomètres carrés le froid la nuit
peut aller jusqu'aux gels le jour le
soleil frappe avec une intensité telle
que c'est ici qu'ont été enregistrés les
records mondiaux de chaleur 58 degrés à
l'ombre bien sûr c'est température de
fournaise enlève toute humidité au sol
il semble qu'il ne puisse y avoir un
environnement plus hostile à la vie et
pourtant il n'en a pas toujours été
ainsi
à cet endroit il y à quelques milliers
d'années des nomades ont fait paître
leurs troupeaux
la végétation y était largement
suffisante pour subvenir aux besoins
d'un grand nombre d'animaux sauvages ce
lieu si près un survivant de cette
époque de la fin de la dernière ère
glaciaire où se produisirent les grands
changements climatiques qui pris vers le
sahara de ces pluies
pour comprendre pourquoi ces régions
sont désertiques observons le sahara à
partir de l'ouest
l'équateur traverse l'afrique sur toute
sa largeur
tout au long de cette ligne les rayons
du soleil frappe la terre
perpendiculairement donc avec un maximum
d'intensité
l'air chaud monte au dessus de
l'équateur et se divise en deux masses
une partie se déplaçant vers le nord
l'autre vers le sud vers les zones plus
froides du globe
parce qu'il est chaud ces terres
transporte un maximum d'humidité en
s'élevant il se rafraîchit l'humidité se
condenser retombe sous forme de pluie
lorsque l'air redescendra à gauche sur
le sahara à droite sur le kalahari
il aura perdu l'essentiel de son
humidité et ne formera plus que de très
faibles nuages les déserts seront
brûlant temps que lui le soleil la nuit
par contre faute de couverture nuageuse
capable de conserver la chaleur du jour
il se refroidir on à l'extrême ce n'est
qu'au coucher du soleil que l'on
découvre les habitants du sahara unis
entre y est l'un des animaux les plus
communs et les plus grands du désert
dans cette partie du monde
ici un fennec
le fennec est un animal particulièrement
sociable qui apprécie la vie de famille
lorsque la lune apparaît beaucoup
d'autres créatures se manifeste un gecko
exactement ce que recherche le fennec
une gerboise elle aussi à la recherche
de nourriture des graines et un autre
petit amateur de gran la gerbille un
caracal une sorte de félin qui aime à la
fois léger remis et les gerboise
c'est la nuit que l'on peut repérer le
plus facilement l'un des animaux les
plus caractéristiques du désert il vit
dans les dunes du namib dans le sud
ouest africain cette race révèle où il a
creusé à la recherche d'une proie et en
creusant soi même très vite on peut en
attraper
le voici c'est une taupe doré un bébé
taupe comme ses parents elle est
complètement aveugle les yeux sont
inutiles à l'intérieur du sable comme
d'ailleurs les oreilles elle n'en a pas
sa tête est prolongé par un petit
morceau de chair assez dur avec lequel
elle se fraie un chemin à travers les
dunes ou éventuellement à travers mes
doigts
les tops dort et mange des proies
relativement grande comme certains
serpents ou les arts
ou de plus petits animaux qui hier avec
trop d'insouciance à la surface
vous
voilà un criquet bien imprudent
on
avec le retour du soleil le désert se
réchauffe très rapidement les mammifères
actif durant la nuit vont se chercher un
abri et céder le terrain à d'autres
créatures qui reçoivent la chaleur
directement du soleil les reptiles nous
nous trouvons dans le désert de
l'arizona à l'ouest des états unis où
l'on peut observer un autre habitant
très curieux du désert c'est un monstre
de gila un des deux lézards venimeux au
monde
en fait il est encore tôt le matin très
rapidement la chaleur l'obligera lui
aussi à trouver un coin loin
ainsi ne peut chasser que pendant de
très courtes périodes à l'aube ou au
crépuscule sa victime cette fois est une
souris du désert
le soleil est à présent levé depuis
plusieurs heures et à la fraîcheur de la
nuit a succédé la chaleur torride
les reptiles se cherchent un abri rester
au frais pendant la journée est un grave
problème aussi pour les oiseaux qui
nichent dans le désert le coucou
terrestre d'amérique ou coureurs de
route la résolue d'une remarquable façon
celui ci apporte une cigale à ces petits
avant que le poussin d'ingurgiter le
parent nourricier extraire liquide de
son estomac et le laisse couler goutte à
goutte
le long de son mec
ainsi avant chaque repas chaque petit
reçoit à boire de gré ou de force
durant le jour les parents se couche sur
le nid non pour réchauffer les oisillons
bien sûr mais au contraire pour les
protéger de la chaleur et pour s'abriter
eux mêmes ils utilisent leur que comme
parasols certains organismes ne peuvent
évidemment échappé aux rayons du soleil
les plantes sont obligés de les ont duré
tout au long de la journée
mais chacune d'elles ses moyens propres
de résistance se ou du désert à des
feuilles qui pousse suivant un angle de
70 degrés quand il fait moins chaud
tôt le matin et le soir la plante
présente largement la phase de ses
feuilles pour recueillir un maximum de
lumière pendant la journée au contraire
elle n'en expose que les bords replier
pour les protéger du soleil
enfin la plante absorbe le sel contenu
dans le sol et elle l'ex crête à la
surface de ces feuilles sous forme d'une
couche blanche qui réfléchit la lumière
et la chaleur et qui conserve ainsi à la
plante un maximum de fraîcheur au sud de
la californie les buissons de créosote
peuvent se passer d'eau pendant dix ans
en arizona par contre les pluies sont
plus fréquentes et les plantes poussent
en plus grand nombre pour beaucoup
d'entre nous le véritable symbole des
déserts c'est le cactus
en fait cette famille de plantes à tige
charnue ne se trouve que sur le
continent américain
il en existe plusieurs centaines
d'espèces dont la plus grande est le
savoir sa tige et plissée comme un
accordéon
ainsi lorsqu'il pleut le cactus ces
temps on pourra absorber un maximum
d'eau ces feux rues se sont transformées
en épines réduisant ainsi la surface par
laquelle l'eau pourrait s'évaporer la
tige elle même est verte car elle est
riche en chlorophylle le pigment qui lui
permet d'effectuer le travail de
photosynthèse dévolu généralement aux
feuilles
les épines protège les jeunes pousses
des ruminants mais elle limite également
l'effet du vent sur la plante est donc
l'évaporation de son humidité à partir
de la tige les grands déserts de sable
en arabie en australie au sahara ont
découragé les voyageurs les plus
intrépides peu de gens sont parvenus à
survivre dans ces contrées pendant une
période prolongée sans aide extérieure
certains effectuent cependant des
voyages réguliers ceux ci sont des
touareg
ils traversent le sahara de bout en bout
transportant des pins de celle qu'ils
négocieront en échange des tofs le grain
et de date mais même les touaregs ne
pourrait effectuer ses voyages sans
l'aide d'un animal spécialiste du désert
le dromadaire
les dromadaires sont merveilleusement
adaptées à cet environnement ils n'ont
que deux orteils réunis par une membrane
ce qui leur permet de marcher dans le
sable sans s'enfoncer profondément
ils ont la faculté de se boucher les
narines pour se protéger des vents de
sable
leur pelage se limite au sommet de leur
corps afin de les protéger de la brûlure
du soleil ailleurs
leur peau est pratiquement glabre pour
éliminer au mieux la chaleur interne
leur corps ils n'ont pas de réserves
d'eau liquide
mais leur boss est rempli de graisse qui
brûlait par le métabolisme libère l'eau
qui entrent dans leur composition
chimique
ces graisses sont aussi d'ailleurs une
source d'énergie c'est pourquoi le
dromadaire ne puise dans cette double
réserve qu'en cas d'extrême nécessité
en fait cet animal peut vivre sans eau
quatre fois plus longtemps qu'un année
dix fois plus longtemps qu'un homme mais
finalement même un dromadaire doit boire
à quelques rares endroits dans le sahara
il est possible de trouver de l'eau en
creusant très profondément dans le sol
là les dromadaires peuvent remplir leur
estomac et il en faut beaucoup pour les
désaltérer dans tous les déserts de la
terre la pluie est un phénomène très
irrégulier la plupart du temps les
nuages qui se forme en altitude
s'éloigne sans éclaté laissant la terre
aride
mais lorsqu'en fin la pluie tombe en
quelques secondes la nature déclenché un
processus d'urgence une ou deux gouttes
suffisent à activer les tiges desséché
aucune de ces plantes ni vivante leurs
mouvements sont simplement dus au
gonflement de leurs tissus morts
absorbant l'eau tué par le soleil elles
ont su conserver leur grain en sécurité
pendant la sécheresse
maintenant que la pluie leur donne une
chance de germination elle les restitue
à la lumière
pour certaines plantes le poids des
gouttes d'eau suffit à déloger leurs
graines d'autres utilisent pour les
éjecter une réaction physique provoquée
par l'absorption de la pluie dès qu'elle
est au sol
la graine commence à bouger ses barbes
gorgée d'eau se gonfle sera 10
permettant à la graine de se placer en
bonne position et de manière que c'est
ridicule puisse pointer directement vers
le sol
parfois dans le désert de l'arizona ces
pluies très rare se transforme en déluge
alors la physionomie du désert se
transforme complètement
ces masses d'eau révèle la présence
cachée de nouveaux habitants celui ci
est un pélobate un crapaud fui soeur les
mâles sont les premiers à sortir du sol
où il s'était enterré il y a un an et
plus rapidement il se dirige vers l'une
des mares éphémères créés par la pluie
et il appelle les femelles
en 24 heures les oeufs sont pondus
fécondés et commencent à éclore
le lendemain la marée rempli de têtards
d'autres créatures sont apparus comme
surgis du néant des crevettes provenant
deux minuscules transportées par le vent
mêlés aux tourbillons de poussière
les têtards se développe très vite se
nourrissant d'algues et de bactéries
abondant dans ces mares
d'autres individus nés de la même
couvent et développe des têtes plus
massive des mâchoires plus puissante
ils sont devenus des carnivores qui vont
jusqu à dévorer leurs frères encore
végétarien
lamarre cependant rétrécit très vite
deux jours encore et elle sera
pratiquement à sécher à la dernière
minute
une averse apporte un ultime répit
certains fêtards sont à présent dotés de
pâte qui leur permettent de quitter la
boue deux semaines seulement après leur
naissance
parmi ces quelques rescapés d'autres
encore mourrons mais avec un peu de
chance certains rejoindront les adultes
et s'interrompt avec eux afin que le
désert les engloutisse jusqu'à la
prochaine averse sans doute dans de
nombreux mois après la pluie pendant
quelques semaines le désert fleuri les
graines libéré par les plantes brûlé se
mettent à germer à une vitesse étonnante
en arizona en australie en namibie au
sahara les déserts se transforme alors
en effet mr tapis multicolore sans
pareille sur la terre